suddenly how does white even do anything  White's Queen can't even counter-attack  there's one check but look how safe  Black's King is no more checks ever  Black's King is super safe okay he  pushes a pawn forward but suddenly  something is about to drop on this  Square  oh it looks okay black is winning wow  you take it with the bishop this is  winning because if the king steps  forward the bishop drops back with the  Discover check winning the queen at the  same time let's go back to the players  is gonna take this game  what a turnaround he just needs to give  another check  due to Smiling he was a queen up and  he's lost it  and we'll see this uh okay White's other  Rook has gone and next move wherever the  King goes Black's Rook is going to jump  out the way with the check Black's  Bishop will capture the White Queen game  over oh wow  wow we have a couple  the queen sacrificing the queen and  winning the game